all right i do have another story today
of another one of these anti-vaxxed
unvaccinated people
that has died of covid but this one is
particularly insidious
because of the details this is someone
who wanted to get infected they wanted
the immunity that they believed getting
infected with the virus would give them
and they are now dead
hannah horka a czech singer
is dead
after intentionally getting infected
with covid the bbc by ben tobias
reporting on this
a folk singer from the czech republic
has died after deliberately catching
covet
57 years old was unvaccinated posted on
social media that she was recovering
after testing positive and was dead two
days later
her son
said she got infected on purpose
when he and his father had the virus so
she could get a recovery pass to access
certain venues
the czech republic reported a record
number of coveted cases yesterday
mr wreck and his father who were both
fully vaccinated both caught coveted
over christmas but he said his mother
decided not to stay away from them
pretend preferring instead to expose
herself
he said she should have isolated for a
week because we tested positive but she
was with us the whole time
proof of vaccination or recent infection
from the virus is required in the czech
republic to go to many venues including
movie theaters bars and cafes
his mother was a member of one of the
oldest czech folk groups assonance she
had wanted to catch covet so there would
be fewer restrictions on her
two days before she died she wrote on
social media she was recovering quote
now there will be a theater sauna a
concert
sunday morning the day she died she said
she was feeling better and got dressed
to go for a walk
her back started hurting she went to lie
down in her bedroom her son says in 10
minutes it was all over she choked to
death
although she was unvaccinated
jan her son stressed his mother didn't
believe in some of the more bizarre
conspiracy theories about covid vaccines
her philosophy was she was more okay
with the idea of catching it than
getting vaccinated not that we would get
microchipped or anything like that
there was no point in trying to discuss
the issue with her as it would get too
emotional instead he hoped that by
telling his story he could convince
others to get vaccinated that's the hope
um
how
scary is it
that she felt good enough to go for a
walk and 10 minutes later was dead that
is
absolutely horrifying and we talk about
sympathy
um you know
every one of these situations is
different
but this is someone who not only refused
to get vaccinated
but deliberately got sick she she
deliberately exposed herself to the
virus refused the best protection we
have against serious illness and death
when we have a highly effective and
protective vaccine
where is this on the spectrum of
sympathy i i don't know
and there's a case to be made that big
picture the recovery passes are kind of
a silly idea now if you test positive in
another country
and you can't get back to the u.s and
because you've tested positive
testing may not be accurate for a long
period of time
in that situation it makes sense to say
i believe this individual has recovered
they should be allowed to go back to the
u.s that that makes sense to me
if you have as a policy to come to
indoor restaurants you got to be
vaccinated or to go to movie theaters
you've got to be vaccinated vaccinated
or recovery certificate
doesn't seem like a very good idea
particularly since we don't really know
that much particularly in the context of
omicron for how long are you protected
after recovery we just don't know the
answers to those questions it seems
problematic to me uh and so
her whole goal here
was
let me get sick to get better to be
recovered to then be able to go places
without being vaccinated
even the pretext of that even that as a
pretext does not seem logical to me but
another tragic story
uh unvaccinated person says i'm gonna go
and get myself sick in order to recover
and have immunity
it didn't work she is dead and we will
have more on this on our instagram you
can find that at davidpakmanshow on
instagram
you can also find me there at
david.pakman
one of our sponsors today is bluechew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence
when it's time
all you have to do is take a short quiz
on their website a licensed doctor
approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discreet package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of blue chews tablets are made in
the usa the entire process is just a few
clicks
go to bluechew.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping